to me
on average
this is the moment that we
we enjoyed seeing each other even though
seconds a few minutes
we do not know how seriously I am
talking about the construction of the wall
and I think that is the biggest fear
that we had to carry out since
we would lose the opportunity to see them
even if it's a few minutes
this is the only way I have of
see my family because obviously they
they can not come or I can go to
there we can not a brother go there
this and of course clear that we are concerned
I think to all the people who are here
we are very worried about that
I think he's going to start with
verify those in the jobs because I
I think the weak point of all people
in jobs because without employment one does not
can live here until now has not
there was no president to express himself
so in such a racist way towards the
Hispanic Mexican people